hey leute bevor wir mit dem eigentlichen
thema anfangen muss ich noch eine sache
loswerden wie ihr seht sie zielen
zwischen ein bisschen anders aus ich
habe um sie kreiert denn das ist das ebt
von meinem neuen youtube-kanal auf dem
ich jetzt seit kurzem videos mache und
das hier ist das letzte was on video
wollte das nur am anfang sagen damit es
auf jeden fall jeder mitbekommt ich
mache weiter in wissenschafts videos nur
eben nicht mehr hier sondern halt auf
meinem eigenen kanal also wenn euch das
interessiert dann schaut unten in die
video beschreibung da findet ihr einen
link zum neuen kanal am ende des videos
werde ich noch etwas detaillierter auf
diesen wechsel eingehen warum wieso
weshalb und ob ich noch in zukunft
lassen die klicks zu machen werde oder
auch nicht also schaut das video bis zum
schluss da kriegt ihr dann alle infos
aber jetzt wirklich zum eigentlichen
video denn heute möchte ich über etwas
sprechen dass mir wirklich sehr am
herzen liegt und zwar geht es mir darum
wie hasserfüllt und respektlos viele
kommentare im internet heutzutage sind
besonders schnell sieht man sowas in der
flüchtlings debatte die zurzeit hier im
land herrscht viele menschen begrüßen
die flüchtlinge hier in deutschland mit
einem lächeln mit offenen armen und
sogar mit geschenken und das ist genial
das ist großartig aber genauso oft hört
man leider vom gegenteil davon dass die
flüchtlinge doch bitte da bleiben sollen
wo sie herkommen oder dass sie uns
deutschen geld wegnehmen das ihnen nicht
zusteht
ich glaube dass viel hass und
unverständnis gestoppt werden kann wenn
man mal wirklich die andere seite des
konflikts betrachten könnte wenn man mal
wirklich verstehen könnte was der
gegenüber eigentlich durchgemacht hat
das gilt für alles im leben nicht nur
für die aktuelle flüchtlingslager wenn
man einmal in die fußstapfen eines
anderen getreten ist dann versteht man
direkt viel besser warum derjenige sich
so verhält und man respektiert
denjenigen auf mehr
klaus overzier ist ein virtual reality
projekt bei dem man in 360 grad den
alltag von sitra miterleben kann
sie lebt in einem flüchtlingscamp mit
84.000 anderen flüchtlingen aus dem
syrischen bürgerkrieg
sie geht zur schule und zeigt uns wo sie
fußball spielt sieht er ist ein ganz
normales mädchen und ihr lebens doch so
anders
die geschichte bewegt einen und noch
viel mehr wenn man sie durch eine vm
brille sieht denn dann guckt man keine
doku über flüchtlinge sondern man ist im
flüchtlingscamp man sitzt im selben raum
wie das mädchen das mit einem spricht
wenn man nach unten guckt dann sitzt man
auf denselben boden wie dieses mädchen
es ist wirklich sehr schwierig zu
beschreiben die sich virtual reality
anfühlt ihr müsst es einfach mal
ausprobieren aber glaubt mir ist es
wirklich eine andere erfahrung
ich glaube dass wenn mehr menschen
verstehen würden was es bedeutet ein
flüchtling zu sein welche ängste diese
menschen haben wo sie herkommen und
warum sie keine andere möglichkeit sehen
als aus ihrer eigenen heimat zu fliehen
dann würden diese menschen nicht mehr
gegen die aufnahme weiterer flüchtlinge
demonstrieren nicht mehr für abschieben
plädieren oder sich darüber freuen dass
menschen auf boden und den lastern
sterben
in den letzten monaten wurde virtual
reality immer häufiger zur
berichterstattung eingesetzt ob wir hier
nach dem erdbeben in nepal oder hier im
kriegsgebiet in syrien
das ausmaß dieser katastrophe wird einem
direkt viel bewusster wenn man in den
trümmern steht wenn man selber seinen
kopf nach links und nach rechts dreht um
zerstörte gebäude zu sehen
wie kann man so die welt verändern indem
man zum beispiel entscheidungsträgern in
der schweiz die noch nie zuvor in einem
flüchtlingscamp diese brillen gibt bevor
jemand über tausende von menschen
entscheidet sollte er zumindest wirklich
verstehen welches leid diese menschen
erleben und klaus overzier hat einen
messbaren effekt auf diese
entscheidungsträger gehabt das projekt
hat wirklich etwas bewirkt wenn euch das
projekt selber ansehen wollt unten in
der video beschreibung findet ihr einen
link dazu in kooperation mit den
vereinten nationen werden jetzt mehr
dieser filme in west afrika und indien
gedreht und dann politikern in der un
gezeigt vielleicht wird sich der effekt
von virtual reality mit der zeit legen
genauso wie kinobesucher inzwischen
immer mehr gewalt und immer schnellere
schnitte gewohnt sind
aber wie ich vorhin sagte es geht mir
nicht nur um flüchtlinge es geht um
empathie für unsere mitmenschen das
projekt perspektive partie spielt auf
einer college party man selber ist als
kamera ein charakter in der geschichte
ein junger student und man erlebt aus
der ersten perspektive was dieser
charakter macht nach einiger zeit auf
der party lernt man china kennen ein
nettes mädchen auf der partie das wohl
etwas zu viel getrunken hat und ein paar
stunden später bewusstlos auf dem boden
liegt doch nun wird es unschön als
träger der vr brille muss man aus der
ersten perspektive miterleben wie der
charakter und sein kumpel das mädchen
aus ziehen während dieses immer noch
bewusstlos ist das video wird schwarz
sobald es zu unschönen wird aber
zurückbleiben ekel und schuldbewusstsein
auch hier wird sehr erfolgreich auf
einen missstand in unserer gesellschaft
aufmerksam gemacht und zwar indem man
leute die mit dem thema sonst gar nichts
zu tun haben an erste stelle stellt und
sie diese situation aus erster hand
erleben lässt virtual reality verstärkt
die emotionale reaktion des trägers in
dem man in eine andere welt eintaucht
das muss nicht immer positiv sein
gewaltspiele können zum beispiel auf
menschen mit aggressions problemen noch
stärkere einwirkungen haben als normale
pc spiele und cybermobbing ist in einer
sue ellen welt noch härter und
entmutigen als text basiert aber ich
denke virtual reality kann uns helfen
uns selber und andere menschen ultimativ
besser zu verstehen und zu respektieren
ob es frauen sind die tagtäglich
belästigt werden ob es ausländer sind
die angefeindet werden oder homosexuelle
sind die angegriffen werden
all das passiert weil es menschen gibt
die sich nicht in die lage von anderen
menschen versetzen können die einfach
nicht verstehen warum der gegenüber so
ist wie er eben ist
und das ist nicht direkt die schuld
dieser leute aber wir müssen etwas gegen
dieses unverständnis in der gesellschaft
tun denn wenn man es recht betrachtet
sind wir nicht ausländer und
einheimische schwule und nicht schule
männer und frauen sondern alle bewohner
dieses planeten und wenn wir schon
miteinander nicht klarkommen was zur
hölle machen wir dann hier überhaupt
vielleicht bin ich ja nur hoffnungslos
naiv aber das wollte ich jetzt einfach
mal loswerden ich bin immer wieder davon
fasziniert welchen unterschied technik
und wissenschaft heutzutage machen
können
ja das ist also das letzte video von
watson ich mache jetzt auf meinem
eigenen kanal weiter videos also schaut
vorbei die ersten videos zum schon
online könnt euch angucken und vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
watson habe ich jetzt über ein halbes
jahr lang gemacht ich fand's super es
war großartig hier meine faszination für
technik und wissenschaft mit euch teilen
zu können
ich habe unglaublich viel gelernt ich
habe mich weiterentwickelt aber ich bin
auch seit einem halben jahr kein
praktikant mehr hierbei clixoom und ich
schon hier auch schon seit diesem halben
jahr und ich denke irgendwann ist es mal
zeit zu gehen
niemand hat hier beef mit irgendjemandem
ich habe das mit christoph schon seit
langem abgesprochen
ich hab mich einfach dazu entschieden
jetzt zu gehen denn ich kann ja nicht
ewig auf dem kanal hier bleiben
vielleicht komme ich nochmal in
unregelmäßigen abständen wieder
vielleicht moderieren christoph und ich
auch mal ein video zusammen wer weiß
ich bin auf jeden fall nicht weg sondern
eigentlich nur einen klick entfernt auf
dem kanal
es würde mich freuen wenn möglichst
viele von euch mit kommen in der
beschreibung findet übrigens noch zwei
links die gesamte playlist mit allen
wurzeln videos vielleicht habt ihr ja
das eine oder andere verpasst und den
link zu meiner lieblings folge von
nordson das war's also alles ist gesagt
es war eine geile zeit es hat mich
wirklich gefreut
danke für alles